les premiers pas à vélo un moment
toujours émouvant pour les parents
samedi 2 juillet à la fête du vélo de
maurepas samuel fait découvrir les
rudiments du cyclisme à son fils quand
on habite juste à côté on a vu les
différents stands donc quand on a voulu
le faire essayer de faire essayer de
petit vélo c'est sympa ça permet de
découvrir les différentes à chaud de la
ville parcours de draisienne pour les
plus petits ou itinéraire en vtt pour
les sportifs
pour cette première édition de tous à
vélo maurepas a souhaité créer un
événement adaptés à tous les niveaux
un moyen de sensibiliser le public un
loisir propre et populaire on est parti
en lien avec nos associations
le cyclotourisme maurepas et l'âge et au
vtt pour organiser une journée à
destination de la population où on
pourrait sortir notre petite reine et
l'utiliser pour parcourir notre belle
ville on va aussi l'utiliser pour aller
faire des courses de proximité plutôt
que de prendre la voiture je crois que
tout le monde à y gagner
un village d'animations installé sur le
parvis de l'hôtel de ville a rythmé
cette journée une cinquantaine de
partenaires étaient présents pour
échanger avec les familles
notre activité c'est pas le tour de
france ce ne sont pas les chronos notre
activité c'est le plaisir sur le deux
roues le plaisir pour les jeunes pour
les moins jeunes pour les femmes
pour les enfants on est aux portes de la
vallée de chevreuse
on est tout à côté du massif forestier
de la forêt de rambouillet on est sur
les routes de la beauce avec ses beaux
moulin donc on a plein plein plein de
paysages à découvrir autour de maurepas
la journée s'est terminée sur la
compétition run and bike qui a réuni 28
équipes
plus de 500 personnes ont participé aux
différentes animations